you look great thank you only for you
for you I even had gelato today did you
really moment I did all of it I love
it's so you know the fact that I learned
that you produced your first film was
mission impossible one and here you are
mission impossible 7. first second part
one we're back to one
it must be a really special Journey for
you to be at this point and and the
success behind it now in every way in
every way to be here everything that
happened you know
now to be here to see everything it's
quite extraordinary it is extraordinary
it is very special it's very special to
see it's very special to see this whole
cast have this moment and know that know
that that's what we're gonna do and to
see new look at these talented you're
bringing everyone together uh and you
know what they're so talented I'm really
happy for them to have this moment now I
was watching your behind the scenes of
your stunt and the ramp and as an
engineer I could not fathom the idea of
the trajectory the force equals mass
acceleration and then you say it's based
on sound and the feeling of the
motorcycle and that's when you jump
what's going through that brain of yours
like what are you saying yourself to
keep yourself calm and focused
engineering because there's as you know
there's a lot of Engineering in there to
figure out that ramp where the bowl is
the speed
um you know we're testing wind
conditions early on that's I set all
that up that's how I approach these
things you know I'm thinking first of
all McHugh and I we come up with
something then we go how do we do it and
I break it down and luckily like I've
been dive skydiving for years and
motorcycles and jumps but you've got to
hone it and make it perfect I'm thinking
about performance I'm thinking about
where's that helicopter going across the
stuff to make sure I don't get blown
going off off the ramp yeah I don't want
to get blown off that ramp and once I
hit it I want that drone to hit me you
know and then when my shoot opens and
you can see it in EPK when I'm in the
bowl and I was testing the wind in that
bowl and I jumped out of the helicopter
and you could see when I opened I was in
the wrong position and I opened and the
parachute turned into the side of the
mountain and I could just at the last
second I was very close my shoot was
very close to the side of the mount so
you really have to watch every aspect of
that to make sure that so I'm thinking
I'm thinking about a few things you are
thinking I've got I've got a few things
on my mind when I'm doing that plus I'm
producing the movie so I'm thinking
about everything and it was day one so
I'm thinking let's get through this
let's get this done now it's my 10th
anniversary at ET Canada I was telling
Amanda congratulations we've been
talking for nine years and chatting
around the world and I've been falling
in love with your movie over and over
and last time we were in Vienna I said I
want to be the leading star of the next
movie do you remember that and you came
to Toronto and you completely called me
out can I show you this video
Great Nails thank you
completely yeah so I need to apologize
to you and say sorry I didn't show up in
Toronto I did I I owe you big time so
because you have no fear I thought I
could be your chauffeur around and drive
you around how's that you drive have you
driven Rome yet no that's right I don't
know I can do it that'll be true I know
but I think that's got to get cleared
through Insurance in the studio and all
of those guys congratulations
maybe we'll see each other
you're amazing thank you so much it's
good to seeing you take care yeah
everything's good happy birthday too
foreign